this video is sponsored by mecharina the
free-to-play immersive third-person
shooter
hey 42 here in december of 1976
coroner to the stars dr thomas naguchi
was faced with an unusual case
he was no stranger to peculiar
post-mortems having conducted autopsies
for the likes of marilyn monroe janice
joplin and natalie wood to name just a
few
but this case was
different the corpse weighed only 23
kilograms and was as shriveled as an
octogenarian scrotum its ears and
fingers were missing and a hangman's
noose had been bolted to its neck which
oozed a thick yellow slime
oh and it was dressed as a cowboy and
spray-painted neon orange
even for hollywood this was a bit weird
the body had been dead for a long time
too lodged inside its chest was a
turn-of-the-century bullet and its veins
had been pumped full of arsenic
nowadays a body full of arsenic would be
a pretty good indicator of poisoning but
back in the early 20th century arsenic
was routinely used for body preservation
someone had clearly wanted to conserve
this corpse
but who was he and how had he arrived at
the coroner's bench
forget everything you think you know
about mobile games because one of the
most ambitious shooter projects of 2021
is here and it's going to change
everything
introducing mech arena playing mech is
the most immersive experience you'll
find on a smartphone and it can only
really be compared with the biggest pc
and console titles and the best part
it's totally free so you start by
choosing which mech you want to use and
then you can jump right into battle with
other players
for me kill shot is the most effective
mech thanks to its maneuverability with
its quick dash ability i also find it
adapts really well to most maps because
you can equip a long distance plasma
cannon with a close-up shotgun so you've
got all angles covered i love the amount
of personalization in this game with
heaps of different mechs available to
unlock and upgrade you can choose custom
weapons skins and even paint jobs this
month mecharina is releasing two awesome
new maps for you to play on along with
its first ever battle pass with loads of
special missions and some brilliant
rewards to win so if you feel like some
extreme mechanical warfare then it's a
great time to start playing mech arena
is completely free to play on android
and ios right now and even better you
can use my personal link or scan the qr
code to get one steel reaper skin
500 a coins and 70 000 credits to help
kickstart your gameplay and if you're
quick you can add me to your friends as
42 and we can play some matches together
so don't wait around
for most of the examination the man's
identity remained a total mystery
it was only when naguchi looked inside
its desiccated mouth
that the mummy's secrets began to
unravel
behind its folded tongue
was a 50 year old penny and ticket stubs
for louis sonny's museum of crime
when the police tried to track down the
owner of said museum they found he died
decades before
they did manage to get hold of his son
though and as luck would have it he was
able to identify this strange corpse
it was none other than elmer mccurdy the
oklahoma outlaw
that was one mystery solved but if
anything it only raised more questions
you see not only had elma mccurdy been
dead for 65 years before he made it on
to dr noguchi's slab
his body had been found in the most
unusual of places
a fairground ride
that in itself was pretty strange but
even stranger was the fact that nobody
who worked at the fairground had any
idea one of their jump-scare mannequins
was actually a real human
corpse so the question was
how did it get there
born in maine in 1880 elmer spent most
of his life drifting around the midwest
working as a minor and a plumber
no one ever kept him on for long but
elma knew that he was destined for
bigger and better things
after a brief stint in the army he
decided it was time to try something new
to follow in the footsteps of the
daredevil desperados of the old wild
west
by 1911 he'd managed to persuade a
couple of his mates to help him rob a
train rumored to be carrying four
thousand dollars in cash worth over a
hundred thousand in today's money the
aspiring assailants successfully stopped
the vehicle and found their way to the
money save
elmer had been taught how to use
explosives specifically nitroglycerin
whilst in the army so it fell to him to
blow the safe open
it was his time to shine or at least it
should have been
as you can probably imagine a little
goes a long way when it comes to
nitroglycerin
but in his excitement elmer didn't just
blow the safe's door off he
disintegrated the entire thing along
with all the cash inside and most of the
train carriage i can only assume he'd
never seen the italian job
unsurprisingly elmer's co-conspirators
didn't invite him along on their next
excursion but that didn't stop him not
in the slightest
in fact just a few months later he'd
already assembled a new team of
transgressors and was planning his next
heist to rob the citizens bank of
chatacua
kansas
they could have gone in through the
front door but that would have been too
conventional instead they spent two
hours bashing through the wall with a
hammer before setting about blasting
open the bank's outer vault
optimistically elmer once again put
himself in charge of the explosives
perhaps a little nervous after the train
incident this time he dialed things down
a bit on the nitro glitter in front
unfortunately whilst he successfully
managed to blow the bloody doors off
the safe within was untouched with time
running out elmer and his crew grabbed a
few handfuls of silver coins and fled
third time lucky
perhaps and it just so happens that the
following month a train was supposed to
pass through oklahoma carrying 400 000
in cash
elmer was sure this was going to be his
big break he could feel it in his bones
and so on the 6th of october 1911 he and
his gang held up the train and clambered
on board
flailing their guns around they searched
for the safe
but it was nowhere to be found and there
was a very good reason for that
they'd rubbed the wrong train
elmer and his crew came away with a
measly 46 dollars a coat the conductor's
watch and two jugs of whiskey in what
the local newspaper later called
one of the smallest train robberies in
history
not quite the notoriety elmer had been
hoping for
deflated and defeated he trudged home
which at the time was a well-appointed
hayloft in his mate's barn
nestled amongst the hay bales he drowned
his sorrows in stolen whiskey promising
himself that tomorrow he would plan the
best heist the world had ever seen soon
he fell asleep
blissfully unaware of the two thousand
dollar bounty that had been placed on
his head
unfortunately for him sheriffs bob and
stringer fenton and their mate dick
wallace were very much aware of this
bounty and they'd used their bloodhounds
to track elmer down the next morning
when a bleedy-eyed elmer stepped outside
the barn the free sheriffs were waiting
for him pistols raised being threatened
with guns was the last thing elma needed
especially on a hangover and so without
thinking he reached for his own weapon
and opened fire you'll never take me
alive he shouted
and they never did
after a gruelling shoot-out elmer lay
dead with a bullet in his chest
the very bullet that dr thomas naguchi
would rediscover
some 65 years later
now it should have been curtains for
elma mccurdy
but in actual fact our oklahoma outlaws
story
is only just beginning
you see elmer's body was taken to
undertaker joseph johnson in pehuska
oklahoma where he was embalmed in
arsenic to keep him fresh until his next
of kin came to claim him
but
no one did
and that left johnson in a bit of a
pickle unless elmer's family came for
the body
johnson wouldn't get paid luckily he had
an idea elmer dead though he was would
have to make back the money for himself
and johnson had the perfect job for him
you see back then gorping at the bodies
of fallen felons was a pretty popular
pastime and embalmers regularly kept
their corpses on display to showcase
their skills
with this in mind johnson removed
mccurdy's funeral suit and dressed him
in a scruffy shirt and faded jeans
he put a rifle in his hand and stood him
in the back room of the funeral home
offering customers the chance to see the
bandit who wouldn't give up
for the price of a single nickel
onlookers were invited to drop this
payment straight into the corpse's open
mouth like a human vending machine
hence the penny found during the autopsy
before long johnson was making a real
killing from this piece of human
taxidermy so much so that he drew the
attention of several carnival promoters
but the embalmed bandit wasn't for sale
not only was the corpse providing
johnson with a steady stream of income
the kids had taken a shine to elmer
they'd kitted him out in roller skates
and took great pleasure in rolling him
around the shop to keep johnson's
customers on their toes
i can only imagine that when in october
two men turned up to finally claim the
body of their deceased brother
they weren't overly impressed you find
him rolling around on skates with a
mouth full of coins
they demanded that johnson hand elmer
over so they could take him home to
their grieving mother
presumably son's roller skates and give
him the burial he deserved reluctantly
johnson complied
rest in peace elmer mccurdy
well
not yet you see these two brothers
weren't actually related to elmer at all
they were in fact james and charles
patterson owners of the great patterson
travelling carnival show
having heard how much of a hit elmer had
become at the funeral parlor they
decided they wanted a piece of the
undead action
posing alongside sideshow staples like
the strongman the alligator girl the
bearded lady and the torture king
elmer was about to get his first taste
of stardom
or at least he would have done if he
could have tasted anything
he was a huge hit but behind the scenes
the pattersons were struggling for cash
and so they used mccurdy as a security
deposit for a loan
a loan which they failed to repay
in the end they were forced to hand
elmer over to their creditor
former police officer louis sonny who
added the stuffed outlaw to his
travelling museum of crime here elmer
was really in his element displayed
amongst waxwork figures of other famous
outlaws like bill doolin and jesse james
he was even used as a prop for several
low-budget movies
including
1967's she freak
which was about as good as it sounds
unfortunately elmer like many others was
a victim of the erratic nature of
popular taste
by the mid-1900s the bottom had kind of
fallen out of the whole celebrity corpse
business
and after louis sonny's death in the
late 1940s elmer lay gathering dust in a
warehouse storage unit
until
when he was sold with a bunch of wax
dummies to the hollywood wax museum
the fame hungry felon had finally made
it to tinseltown
but not as abandoned in fact
not even as the corpse of a bandit
elmer's body had deteriorated to such an
extent
that nobody realized it was a genuine
human body
the wax museum's owner eventually
decided
elmer wasn't realistic enough to be
exhibited and so our outlaw changed
hands once again becoming the property
of pike amusement park in long beach
california
here he was given a coat of bright
orange paint hung up from a noose and
by some weird coincidence dressed as a
cowboy again in an unintentional nod to
his long-lost past
for the next four years he hung in the
park's ghost house
an actual dead body amongst an
assortment of grimacing ghouls blood
splattered demons and pop-up
poltergeists
who knows how long he would have stayed
there had hollywood not come calling
once more
in 1976 the ride was leased out to
universal studios to film an episode of
the six million dollar man for those of
you who aren't familiar with your 70s
sci-fi the six million dollar man was an
american tv series featuring everyone's
favorite astronaut turned crime-fighting
cyborg
steve austin
and his adventures as a secret agent for
the us government
the spook house was to be the backdrop
for an action-packed chase scene between
steve the nuclear-powered protagonist
and a german spy
while sprucing up the set a prop man
caught sight of elmer's fluorescent
figurine dangling from the right ceiling
his body was at this point so light that
the rush of the rickety passenger carves
left him swinging violently through the
air like a demonic hammock
worried that this might distract from
the action of the scene the prop man
pulled elmer down from the noose
only he hugged a little too hard and
elmer's fragile arm broke off in his
hands
and looking down at the damage the prop
man saw something that made his stomach
churn
instead of crumbling plaster
he was confronted with the grisly
remnants of aged muscle and broken bone
production ground to a halt and the body
was whisked away to the coroner's office
the story of the funhouse mummy made
headlines across the country and
garnered elmer mccurdy the international
fame he had always dreamt of just go to
the show it's never too late to achieve
your dreams
after his autopsy elmer was transported
back to oklahoma where he was finally
laid to rest at the summit view cemetery
in guthrie
he was buried next to the famous outlaw
bill doolin founder of one of the most
powerful outlaw groups at the old west
and no doubt one of elmer's heroes
by this time old elmer had picked up
quite a fanbase and over 300 people
attended his graveside service
but to make sure no one else could ever
profit from his tired mummy
the coroner ordered that two feet of
concrete be poured over his casket
just in case it might have taken him 65
years but elmer mccurdy the oklahoma
outlaw
now finally
rests in peace
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history told in a
refreshing way and packed full of
incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you